okay I think we got this going hey
everybody the folks doing howdy
yeah that's a nice way to start all
right nice to see folks in hello Carolyn
hello pirates oh yeah
yes my dirty water today the the filters
busted something also I wanted to show
off the glass let's see if it'll show up
might see it better later but I was
given a set of Harry Potter glasses for
as an early Christmas gift to someone
who when we met up I had forgotten to
bring the gift that I got for them so at
the very least the least I can do is
show that these are being put to
immediate use I think we're drinking the
same kind of water
oh my favorite video game music um I
think if you were if you were to put my
and put a gun to my head I would say
Secret of Mana um it's close though
like I I go back to sixteen bitterer
video game soundtracks and you know II
even accounting for you know the
digitized sound Chrono Trigger Final
Fantasy six Secret of Mana
but even you'll be on that Super Metroid
had a great soundtrack Donkey Kong
Country at a phenomenal soundtrack
knives outlet is amazing and I'm mad
about it I have heard
I believe could have linked two things
about that movie I have not seen it yet
I don't know if I'm going to get to it I
would like to but you know life from a
Hufflepuff to a slither and loving the
Hat thank you very much
yeah it's a little chilly where I am not
so much that I need the wildling robe
this time but yeah I did it I did need
to cover the noggin how dare you wear a
sling on hatton and smile as a fellow
Slytherin we scowl no those of you who
aren't subtle and don't know how to
infiltrate scowl those of us with a bit
more ahead planning know how to smile so
that our intentions are not always known
I love your sorting hat videos what
other series would you like to sort um
there's a few that I've got on the to-do
list I I would like to sort Doctor Who
the Companions because I did the doctors
so I'd like to do the Companions I'd
like to do Star Wars I need to bring Liz
back and keep doing the MCU because we
only did phase one characters so I want
to get back and to do that again I got I
do a video on it because my videos on
this topic are not something like better
viewed stuff so I pushing more content
doesn't you know that doesn't do
exceptionally well doesn't make it a lot
of sense but I know in my head I've
sorted most of the cast of Shira and had
fun doing that only a month away until
Jody wears a tux
yeah the tux is a good look I I approve
of that look I still like her standard
outfit but I want to talk some ah yeah
what Hogwarts house would you place
Clara in oh I don't know cuz I'd have to
figure out her character first it's
gonna be really weird revisiting Clara
I'm hoping that I'll enjoy or better but
you know she want a full series without
being properly characterized she was a
MacGuffin for a while there before she
was a character and I still feel like I
can't easily sum her up loved your
reaction video on the other channel
thank you I'm surprised at least last I
checked only one person commented on how
abnormally low my voice was for that
because I did it first thing in the
morning after waking up so I had you
know just waking up voice because
slytherins are the most like water most
likely to change you get more types of
Slytherin they're the house with the
most variants hmm I'm thought of it that
way but it kind of makes sense doctor
who has a scorpion tux as a woman in a
tux and maybe a scorpion lady - oh my
fandoms are starting to take cues from
each other I see what you did there you
should look at the last airbender anime
it's a great show you should do you
could do great videos on it look here's
the thing there's a couple of things
that keep me from getting around to the
last airbender happy christmas from
south carolina and to you the first is
just time raw time but a big part of it
is honestly I don't think I'm gonna get
any decent video content out of it
because honestly it's one of those
series that has been picked over - yeah
by its fans and four years out because
it's been wrapped up for so long it has
been picked over very it's been picked
over in terms of reactions you know
episode by episode reviews big thematic
video essays like it I'm not sure
there's any meat left in that bone left
on those bones as far as me trying to
make content which does also bounce it
back on the list for me a little bit
any Doctor Who villain as a Hufflepuff
the cat nurses yeah the cat nurses
possibly one could make an argument for
either Hufflepuff or Gryffindor with
them I think I'd have to uh I have to
ponder on that that's a good that's an
interesting question
first episode of series 12 is called spy
fall that might be the most Tad's joke
Doctor Who story name ever yeah don't
love that name I mean we'll see what we
get with the episode I'm not gonna judge
it based solely off a name but don't
love it
it's BS that you can't watch the
original version of new hope legally I'm
I'm honestly surprised that since having
gotten Star Wars Disney has not released
original cuts you know just as an option
not to say they'd like get rid of the
special edition I have to wonder if it
was conditional on their acquiring the
license from George Lucas because I
would think that'd be an easy money
maker right there is to release those
because yeah a lot of us are still
clamoring for that
think let's knock off with or haha
did you know Billy Dee Williams recently
came out as gender-fluid I did I shared
that on Twitter as soon as I found out
actually my friend Ryan who is on the
logo he's the one with the lightsaber he
he put me on to it he was the the first
one to bring my attention to it and that
may be very happy I mean the the way in
which he describes his fluidity isn't
quite how I experienced mine but gender
fluidity in and of itself is a very
nebulous concept and just the idea of
somebody that with that much you know
prestige in history and just saying yeah
I'm like that oh all that makes me happy
ah see uh uh back up for a second here
have you seen the new black widow
trailer I have and I'm not gonna tell
you what I think about it cuz I'm gonna
do a video on it which is probably
probably gonna end up being an
additional video tomorrow cuz I don't
want to wait on any longer than that
see sorry I'm trying to get back where I
was
I'll be filming if Jodie doesn't say bow
ties are cool ah actually I kind of I
kind of hope that she says I actually
don't really care for bow ties but
where's it anyway like maybe I'm weird
for wanting that if you lived in the his
dark materials world and had a date
demon opposite sex animal
personification of your soul what would
it be I don't know
you need to Rose have read the books and
haven't watched any of the stuff yet
I've seen bits and pieces of the Golden
Compass movie I don't know well enough
to say cuz I don't know enough about how
that works besides the fact that if it's
meant to be
the opposite sex I suppose it would be
going off my sex assigned at birth but I
would imagine during gender fluidity
would complicate at least part of that
inherently dimensions in times or
dimensions int I'm or the Star Wars
Holiday Special
no you go in the corner you think about
what you just did what haha why does
your avatar and the council of geeks
have no boobs because there's an
alternate version which is me presenting
feminine and that one has boobs that's
and that not hat that'll debut wins at
some point this month whenever my next
lgbtq+ video goes up and I haven't I
need I need to lock down the docket
because I got to post that on patreon I
think because I could be wrong I think
every time Lucas released a new cut of
the original trilogy he destroyed the
previous cuts I've heard that but that's
like there's no verification on that and
I have a hard time buying that only
because if he did that that means that
he can't he's lost a resource to tinker
with so that doesn't quite make sense to
me I'm not saying it's impossible to be
the case but I consider that unlikely
how caught up are you on Brooklyn
nine-nine not at all I am a boy I've
started working my way through series
four of Supergirl I'm caught up on the
good place I am looking forward to see
how that wraps up but the other
theorists cuz Liz has taken to watching
this as comfort food and I caught a
couple of episodes while I was over at
her place and now I'm like yeah I gotta
start from the beginning
watching The West Wing which I'd never
seen before which is actually kind of
surprised because I I do like I like
Aaron Sorkin's style I like rapid-fire
dialogue I like people to talk faster
and more clever than they do in real
life because it's shows and movies
mm-hmm
last week was crap for me first I ended
up with a cold that had me sick in bed
then I found out my father has type 2
diabetes oh geez Connor I'm really
really sorry to hear that and I hope I
hope things I bought you get better and
I hope that your family is able to you
know work around and with that as best
as can be managed that's uh that's a
rough go that's not a fun way to go into
the winter I'm looking forward to
finishing my exams going home finishing
Hannibal that that's something to look
forward to and cooking with my sister
those last two aren't related
well played Ben can I just say your hair
looks awesome
thank you I'm annoyed at how long I've
gone without getting the color refresh
like it's not too bad that's part of why
I picked the colors I did they fade
nicely but it is getting to the point
room like ah I got a I got a schedule
some time but again that's story of my
life scheduling time hmm do you think
there should be a Jane bond if so should
player well no I don't I mean that there
have been plenty of really good female
spy movies um none of which have had
sequels so far as I know but like it's
not hard to build a franchise around a
female spy we don't need to hijack James
Bond in order to do it you know do a
sequel to atomic blonde I mean it's
probably too much time has passed but
long kiss goodnight could have totally
used a sequel that would
terrific finally to a spinoff from
Mission Impossible with the God I can't
remember her her name now but the the
the the first end in so far as I know
only recurring female character who was
in both five and six well not only cuz
Michelle Monaghan has been in more than
what the only female spy characters have
been in more than one and but I've now
lost the character Faust I can't
remember now but there's plenty of ways
to do it there's no need to do a literal
flip on James Bond besides which it just
sounds like a parody if you're gonna do
it seriously you really don't do that if
you want to do it as a joke in poking
fun at James Bond shirt that's a way to
do it fine but if you're trying to be
serious about it no don't don't do that
what's the worst movie you've ever seen
and why is it so bad I don't know
there's a couple of movies that tend to
come to my mind well I think worst
movies that I've seen and there's
basically three that jump up in my mind
and they're all bad for decidedly
different reasons and those are robot
monster dead man and the haunted world
of L super beast oh so these are all bad
for very different reasons robot monster
is bad for the traditional reasons it is
poorly written poorly acted terrible
effects clunky bad progression horrible
pacing just bad it's just a bad movie
dead man is just has its head so far up
its own but it is so friggin pretentious
I lost my mind
and then the haunted world of L super
beast o is an animated film that is well
animated and has some good comedic songs
in it but absolutely everything about it
offended me to my core and I don't mean
in a like clutching my pearls or it hurt
my feelings because it made fun of gay
people I mean like I was a fan
did that people devoted time and money
and talents cuz there was clearly some
talent on display to that frickin script
I I found that very offensive and I
actually hold a grudge against Tom Papa
as a result for his part in that thing
if you've never seen any of these don't
seek any of them out just know let's see
what would you say is your favorite work
from Aardman Animations for me it's toss
between wallace and gromit on the short
called bore story I'm sure I've seen war
story I mean I've gone back and I've
probably seen curse before curse of the
where rabbit more than anything else
that I've seen from them but I mean like
all their stuffs good meaning David
Tennant and Matt Smith this weekend I'm
terrified don't pass out Joseph have fun
I haven't met those folks in particular
but you know I've only ever heard good
things about you know meeting Doctor Who
cast members so I think you'll be fine
if in the script I'm writing there's
only one major female character I know
this is bad but I don't trust myself
usually to write female characters
should I try to change that I mean first
of all don't try and change anything
until you finish a draft that's honestly
that that's the biggest hurdle for
writing in general is actually focusing
enough to finish your first draft so if
you have an idea for a story just write
it get to the end and then once you have
a complete draft you will be in a much
better position to go in and do things
like alter characters gender if you feel
like you should have another character
or add characters in or take them out or
realize something isn't working don't do
it while you're still working on your
first
as far as broadly speaking it completely
depends on the story you're telling not
every story needs a female character not
every story makes sense to have a female
character there are movies that I love
that have no female characters 12 Angry
Men Glengarry Glen Ross the thing there
are no female characters in any of those
and that is not a detriment to any of
them
so never insert a female character
simply because you feel like you're
supposed to because that is the heart of
tokenism have a reason to do it even if
that reason is a writing challenge
because you know that's hard for you to
do that's still a reason and I'll take
it that's fine but like have something
do you think Kate Stewart is coming back
and spy fall because 13 is talking to
someone she knows on the phone maybe I
haven't thought about Kate Stewart in a
while I really liked her when she first
got introduced and I got annoyed with
her a little bit with almost every
subsequent appearance you made
have you seen super villain bowl by arts
pure entertainment I have not so no
comment to be had there writing advice
podcasts I joke of course well I mean
I'm gonna have the author Diaries going
up on the breakroom so that's about as
close as you're gonna get
i i'm always here's the thing you ask me
i will happily answer i'm always happy
to answer questions about things like
writing but honestly take any
vice that I give I have two things
published they both were self-published
and neither of them is a traditional
work of you know written fiction you
know one was a play the other was an
autobiography by way of an advice book
so you know it as much as I like to
think I have a decent handle on story in
structure and character and theming
etcetera you know maybe stick a pin in
following too much of my advice until I
actually get the freakin novel out you
can read it and decide if my advice is
worth listening to
at all cuz maybe it isn't favorite
animated Christmas movie ooh that is
hard I'm gonna I'm gonna cheat and allow
for specials because to me most of my
favorite Christmas animes stop for
specials not proper movies so how the
Grinch Stole Christmas the Chuck Jones
animated obviously that's right up there
the other one that I am super nostalgic
for is um twas the night before
Christmas rankin/bass now when people
think rankin/bass Christmas they think
the stop-motion stuff like Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer I didn't grow up in
any of that I have seen most of it at
this point but they did a traditional 2d
animated thing of twas the night before
Christmas focusing on this family of
mice and I still like that
I still think those songs in that are
really good yeah I think I'm probably go
with that one there's something about
that one good hits me in the soft spot
I'm looking forward to rewatching Daleks
in Manhattan evolution of the Daleks
this week I love them when I was a kid
not watch them in years I wonder what
I'll think I'm curious see what you
think as uh I'm on record as not being a
fan of those at all not even on the
ReWalk
nearly done draft one of trem - Oh
congratulations Alex that's terrific I
do I have tram it's right down there had
finding time to read is really really
tough I lean on audiobooks a lot these
days
which reminds me I need to really bump
up my schedules trying to get an audio
version of skirting gender done in the
new year that's on my to-do list
but I won't send it to your way until
you have the time for book one I do
appreciate that that's very thoughtful
but I want you to get too too much in
your house what would be your Ark and
betrayal of the doctor if you acted or
wrote the doctor I have a lot more ideas
about how I would play the doctor as an
actor than how I would write the doctor
and and I think part of that is I've
never really taken a crack at writing
the kinds of sci-fi stories that doctor
who does I've written some sci-fi short
stories but they're much more in the
traditional sci-fi vein of commentary on
humanity as opposed to the fun adventure
sort of end of things which is more
Doctor Who's bread and butter but like I
would I really hope I really hope that
next year I can pull together and
finalize like a design for a costume for
my version of the doctor man I always
say my I mean like that I would play and
if the only question will be whether or
not I will try and make people be
subjected to me trying to do a British
accent if and when I ever do that but
like I yeah I I even know what the what
the recurring trademark line would be
but yeah I think about this stuff too
much sums
have you read Tom Baker's doctor who
books scratch Minh I haven't I intend to
get the audiobook at some point martyrs
have you seen this French film where the
antagonists are trying to find out if
there is anything to look forward to
no sounds very existential which might
mean it's good and probably means it's
super depressing in my mind like the the
epitome of the existential dread stories
still no exit which I got to know fairly
well because I abridged it for someone
to be able to perform it as a one Mac to
play let's see basic premise is it's a
campy sci-fi comedy with teenagers doing
insane crap and getting trapped in
insane situations would you say that
justifies a mostly male cast I mean if
it is if your group dynamic is people
who have you know been friends for a
long time and you wish to have it be
established that this is basically a
boys club of friends sure that works
that's fine again you know what I mean
it feel free to experiment if you want
to try having a female character in
there but like I said just don't just
don't beat yourself up and as always get
to the end of the draft it's always much
easier to
just something that you know exists
rather than try and fix something in the
middle of building it just once santa
claus is coming to town on Monday haha
that's actually I've never seen that one
start to finish I've seen bits and
pieces of that one
Disney Plus has the Muppets Christmas
Carol and that is everything I watched
that this weekend with Liz I hadn't seen
it in a while I forget how crazy
faithful that is to the original work
like stunningly so have you seen the six
doctor episode time lash excuse me
getting hiccups here so first one I saw
it's usually agreed upon as his worst
some people say to two doctors or twin
dilemma I haven't seen time lash yet I'm
trying to think I haven't seen a ton of
Sixth Doctor stuff because it hurts but
I've seen twin dilemma I've seen the two
doctors I've seen vengeance on Pharos
but it's been a while and I need to
rewatch that and I've seen revelation of
the Daleks which was a good story but
did very little for the doctor ie he
didn't need to be there for that story
to happen and he has almost nothing to
do in it and that bugs me and he's very
telling that that's usually agreed to be
the best of the Colin Baker era and he
is barely in it for all intents and
purposes I'm looking forward to having
plum pudding this Christmas oh man
I haven't had plum pudding in ages and I
have actually had it like uh-huh I come
from a super waspy family and I have had
things like plum pudding and they would
have mincemeat pies I never ate those
but I never knew you thought being the
doctor it's a dream of mine as an
aspiring actor I have an outfit and I've
written out stories I'd love the BBC to
use but won't realistically yeah I've
never here's
as much as I've come up with it with
this ridiculous notion I have in my head
like basically what a trailer me as the
doctor would look like or - um I know
what how the regenerating regeneration
will go down and so I'd like I know how
that would look
and then like cutting together a trailer
so like this is really dreaming if I
could get the use of someone who is
better at actually filming things like
who knows properly how to shoot stuff
worth a darn like in a dream world I
would I I would put that I'd get that
shot and put that together but you know
I don't know I don't know if that will
ever happen I highly recommend checking
out ralph the movie maker he's a film
reviewer who also makes his own short
films whether or not you agree with him
he's definitely worth the watch alright
I'll try I will try and remember to
check him out you're probably gonna have
to remind me if I wrote the doctor I
would show him or her as the last
incarnation before they became the value
art and being so desperate to prevent it
probably a terrible idea but it's an
idea I don't know if it's a terrible
idea like am I the only person who has
no interest in seeing the valley rd
concept picked up like I just I feel
like they've done enough over the last
couple regenerations to make the doctor
themselves dark I mean the Time Lord
victorious was basically the valley art
and the the level of fear that the
universe basically had of Matt Smith he
may not have been behaving by that like
the valley are but for all intents and
purposes everyone was treating him like
he was I don't know how much you get out
of actually trying to mind that actual
storyline I don't know how much you get
that hasn't
and have been done to some extent I
don't know and that's not like the
Valliere was a bad idea
I don't know how it was executed I still
haven't watched trial of a Time Lord but
you know it it's a perfectly fine idea
but it's like I think we've all been
dwelling with the idea of the valley or
so long I think if they ever did bring
that concept back we'd all be let down
it's as one of the things been too long
I'd rather have the dream master back
before the valley art oh boy the valley
is my favorite Doctor Who villain that
being said I agree more so because I
don't trust the new show to do him right
there I feel like the valley are
concepts was done much better with the
dream look at see there you go that's
what I'm talking about the thing with
the valley art is that he was a being
between the doctors 12th and final
incarnations so some people claim it's
Time Lord victorious or Matt's 13 etc
well look at this point we have to
accept that the valley yard as we saw
him in trial of a Time Lord never came
to exist because we've missed the window
so it would already have to be a
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey explanation as
to how it even happens because if you're
gonna do you are gonna have to kind of
cover that but like in my mind he was a
possible outcome not a definite and like
again I have a wash it but my
understanding was that was always that
he was a possible result not a foregone
conclusion which is one of the reasons
that I find it odd that so many people
kind of demand to bring him back funny
idea for a one-off if someone gives 13 a
cocky nickname such as northern blondie
or Jane blonde perfect for Skyfall I
would not be shocked if someone makes a
james blonde joke
also trial of a Time Lord was a mess in
the valley rd was done much better an
audio like The Sixth Doctor well I mean
this kind of a that's almost a given at
this point why do you think there are no
Doctor Who computer games I think there
are
I haven't played any of them I know
there have been a couple of things over
the years I've never played any of these
things have you seen Jo Jo rabbit I have
not I would like to I don't know if I'm
gonna get to it before the years over uh
top three classic monsters you want new
hukou I mean Omega top the list always
could bring back the forget what the
call whatever um whatever su tech was
don't bring him back but his race could
have them get encountered again I think
that could be interesting um and I
hacked let's go with the draconians the
problem is the valley art is shown to
survive the end of trial hence why he
still exists in other Doctor Who media
like Big Finish I mean okay but again
like I don't I don't have a frame of
reference on that
nothing like a cigar whiskey our
favorite channel on the live stream I
don't smoke but you know have you seen
knives out i have not i would like to
but again i don't know if I'm gonna get
to it I'd I I went with a friend who I
haven't seen in a while and she wanted
to see this so last night I went and saw
last Christmas and as much as it is very
far outside the wheelhouse of this
channel I think I'm gonna have to do a
review and you know start a new sub
series that may never
another entry but I think I'd have to
call it what did I just watch
holy crap
like I was not expecting it to be good
it didn't really look like my cup of tea
from the get-go but oh wow thing Wow
it had off the rails in some really
bizarre ways that I'm gonna have to talk
about just a process but that was a
thing that happened so weird
I love the Doctor Who adventure games
released on PC perfect format for Doctor
Who games shame they blew of there
they blew all their money and canceled
doing more Oh see again I don't like I
don't game much so I haven't paid
attention
would you eat green eggs and ham with
Sam I am
I would eat green eggs and ham not with
Sam I am he's pushy bugger I don't care
for him should a female bond also be a
womanizer to screw twice with certain
vocal groups it's an option
certainly I recommend a show called
Miranda it's on Netflix and his bloody
hilarious I have not even heard of that
one although have you heard of Dave down
under he does videos showing the
evolution of classic cartoon characters
I recently did one on Popeye oh I've
seen some of those they're not bad and
well they're good they're good for what
they are but like it's not something
that I watch a ton of or would watch a
ton of sooo tech was a no siren thank
you John thank you very much we've seen
one or two others in books and comics
I'd love to see the sea Devils Oh
see Devils is a good call yeah we have
the site Laurie's back we should bring
the Sea Devils back Omega draconian
stalls maybe chameleons totally the
celestial toymaker I've never seen that
one has anyone seen the mr. Rogers movie
I'd be mine to see that also saw that
this past weekend um I shot a review of
for that but that's that's gonna go open
the bait to the break room cuz I only
had like six seven minutes worth of
thoughts on it there isn't a ton to say
about it it's good i if you actually
want a mr. Rogers movie like about him
this is not that you're better off
watching the documentary won't you be my
neighbor but Tom Hanks is very good in
the world and there are some moments
again usually around Fred Rogers himself
that are really well done and there's
one that freakin heck it's magical what
happens and it was amazing it was
amazing moment in a theatre but that's
not the entirety of the film and most of
the stuff that isn't him is not bad but
it's very by the numbers it's very
predictable so it was it was pretty good
overall but there are there there's what
if you see the movie you'll know the
moment I'm talking about it's about
midway through but oh man it was
incredible
um and I do actually talk about it in
the in the review when that goes up um
I'm not like trying to keep a regular
schedule with the breakroom or any man
but I am trying to be sure to get stuff
up there steadily let's see now that
I've rambled on for a bit I'm now behind
on things again if I got to play the
doctor I would go with a gambler
archetype a bored reckless immortal who
takes massive risks to prove how clever
they are hmm like part of my thing with
if I was gonna play the doctor I would
play a doctor who gets
flustered a bit more when when things go
belly up a bit more girth um you know
aggravated when things when things don't
don't do it what they're supposed to or
they don't stop going wrong sort of one
of the things that that I would go in
let's see actually got the opportunity
to quote you earlier this week and I'm
happy because I love that quote I'm
curious now as to what the poll was
should the Sea Devils retain their fish
nets well yeah I mean that's just
fashion are you going to watch are you
going to rewatch all the Star Wars films
in anticipation of episode 9 I'm
debating skipping the spin-offs in
Episode one uh no I mean the thing is I
know the original trilogy like the
absolute back of my hand I could quote
the entire original trilogy start to
finish including the alien dialogue so I
don't need to re-watch that I don't
really want to rewatch the prequels um I
really don't want to watch the last Jedi
again like no I just want to go in and
take in rise of Skywalker as its own
thing I don't need to I don't need to
build up what I'm comparing it to I need
to try and take it as fairly as I can I
don't think that's gonna do it favors
and that's not me saying I don't think
it'll be good I just don't I don't need
to be thinking about every other Star
Wars movie while I'm watching the thing
but that's me you know to each their own
rather than old Time Lords we should
have on already seen pick up besides
such as the Corsair from the doctor's
wife oh okay
so so you mean sort of picking up the
more of the sort of the toss off or
going in different directions with new
time would mean maybe I don't I
personally want to see the Time Lords
really all that much I've just never
found them interesting about 90% of the
time if you can bring any room bring in
any writer for Doctor Who who would it
be what would you have them do I gives
to bagful of dr. light story and h-bomb
or Gaia a historical with HP Lovecraft
well first of all you don't actually do
a historical with HP Lovecraft the
person set something in at HP Lovecraft
setting dual love crafting story don't
actually involve the character because
um you're gonna have to depict him a
super racist cuz he was super racist and
that's not gonna be fun
so I like the fact that Lovecraft is a
character who pops up in a lot of media
like I'd like as a character actually
kind of annoys me a little bit just
because pretty much any time that
happens they don't address that and like
yeah I try not to harp on about this too
big but this is a case where it's not
just a guy with issues wrote some cool
stories you read enough of his work and
you realize how much his racism is
informing the stories that he wrote it's
baked into a lot of those things and hey
yeah and the level of avoidance some
people have of that really does irritate
me and I'm not knocking Lovecraft
stories I like Lovecraft stories I I
figured out what the one was that God
months ago now somebody asked me what my
favorite Lovecraft story was and I could
describe it but I couldn't remember what
the outsider that's the name of the love
of my favorite Lovecraft story which is
one of his least cosmic horror he ones
but I just really really liked it I
really liked the way it was presented
the way it progressed in the way that it
can
it was just masterfully done and put
together but I've read a fair amount of
his stuff and I do enjoy reading it so I
you know I say all this stuff about how
racist he was that's not a reason to not
really snot for me but like don't don't
be like duh don't bring politics and
it's like it's in the work it's in the
writing it's right there I'm gonna have
to hop over to the discord in a minute
following John Sims masters death and
world enough in time what kind of master
do you think would be good foil for 13
I'm not sure I'm not sure what to do
with the master at this point I'd like
to draw upon the past arc just from my
characterization like powdi did I mainly
draw up on eleven eight four and twelve
I have a little bit of all of them but
those are the mains I I wouldn't I
personally wouldn't go in with that in
my head I suspect that I'd probably end
up picking up pieces from from them but
that wouldn't be like my methodology
going in but that again that's just
that's just me I try very hard not to be
super overly influenced by other
performances if I can help it
says a guy who hasn't acted in three
years it's been a while
following Johnson oh I read that one
dude another season of who with
Eccleston or season of McGann I would
say Eccleston because McGann we've got
Big Finish
Eccleston we've only got the 13 episodes
most knew who who doctors have a kiss
scene with them in it should 13 have one
no and neither should any of the others
have had them either I don't know why
that keeps getting in there talking
about problematic authors how do you
feel about Ender's Game the movie that
is I never saw it because orson scott
card has a producing
credit on it so I refuse to do
participate I refuse to see it in the
theater order entik because that would
have been putting money in the man's
pocket and even though I could probably
stream it at this point in a way that
doesn't excessively or overtly
financially benefit him I still don't
wanna just know now see thoughts on the
stranger if you don't know what it is it
was a series of Doctor Who knockoff
starring Colin Baker and previous Doctor
Who actors after Doctor Who was canceled
I have no thoughts cuz I hadn't really
heard of that um have you ever wanted to
watch a movie or show based solely on
the actor who appeared on Doctor Who or
any other show or movie like I've been
guilty of that I used to be guilty of
that like when I was young but as I got
older I'm realizing I need to stop
trying to follow actors just because
they were in a thing I like I need to
stick to you know things that look like
stories I would enjoy cuz you know yeah
I think I did that with the cast of The
Lord of the Rings movies for a little
bit you know cuz I was young and stupid
have you been able to watch Klaus on
Netflix I haven't had the time yet um I
would like to I have it on my list I'm
hoping my kid will be interested in
seeing it but you know I just I that's a
dice roll um although I've gotten her
into Shira and she says she'll be up to
4 watchin more if she's five episodes in
which means she's met Scorpia
that makes me happy I would draw upon
the mysterious risk trickster aspect
like the second and Seventh Doctor the
unpredictability with a fourth doctor
but is willing to get more physical like
the third doctor okay
I'm making a mandatory Duty that I start
going to bed early here because if I
don't is gonna be seriously detrimental
to my health
ya know a good sleep schedule is very
very important after what occurs left
the role of the doctor do you think
Chibnall will stay out as showrunner if
I were to bet money I would I would
expect Chibnall to leave before Whitaker
does just that a guess for a while I
wanted a regeneration to go wrong
leaving the doctor with amnesia
mm-hmm-hmm and to slowly rediscover
themselves within past personalities
coming out of order the amnesia thing is
I don't know it's just so played out in
general the reason I suggested a
Lovecraft historical is because of
themes of artists versus art I love
h-bombs essay on him about how his work
draw in LGBTQ fans if that was the angle
for the actual story that could be
interesting that'd be a hard needle to
thread though to do that and also tell a
fun Doctor Who story cuz it's it's a
complicated enough issue to try and
tackle that and tell a narrative at the
same time tricky time for discord Thank
You Carolyn sorry I am gonna get grabbed
this last one before I hop over have you
heard the original third doctor theme
that has Jon Pertwee singing you like
half but I cannot recall it okay I'm
hopping over to the discord which means
I'm going to completely lose track of
what's going on in the chat so if you
asked a question that I didn't get to
hold on to it and ask it again want to
come back so give me a minute here and
to get the obligatory plugs in the
discord is a perk exclusive to the
patreon supporters so let's see
how's the beta reading going yeah okay
so I'm continuing the beta reading
process with my novel I've heard back
from multiple people at this point and
actually it has been super helpful um I
haven't done I haven't done like massive
changes to the story at all but I have
rearranged stuff I have condensed a few
things I have changed the order of some
of the chapters and I have made clear
some things that were only alluded to
and also extended some things for some
characters based on the feedback I got
and especially with beta reading helps
to get feedback from multiple people so
that you can get a sense of whether or
not something keeps coming up or whether
it's a fluke um and also depending on
how detailed the feedback is you get you
get a sense of whether or not that
person's writing sensibilities how close
they are to your own you know and you
know go with a grain of salt of that but
I've really enjoyed the process of
getting feedback from beta readers shows
movies or games you thought were too
short lived or didn't receive the praise
you thought it deserved ie that I'd like
have to dedicate something to that I'm
not gonna come up with anything off the
top my head
hmm excuse me I definitely want to see
how the good place wraps up also fairly
intrigued by The Witcher I've watched
there's new trailers for that I think I
haven't watched any of those which
starts streaming later this month oh god
it's that soon I can I can't think of
any major movie releases I'm chomping at
the bit for though I might go see the
last Star Wars movie if I can find time
to watch the two previous I mean I'm
gonna go see Star Wars that one's like
that one's a given I'm looking forward
to the next and last season of Lucifer I
know you don't like it but I really want
to know how everything is wrapped up I
hope it ends well I I couldn't get into
it but I hope it ends well for the
people who like it I'm hearing some cool
things about black panther 2 like dr.
doom being one of the villains and also
Namor the Submariner is gonna be in it
as well how reason is that info though
because I remember hearing both those
things like a year ago and they sounded
like early pitches I like I don't even
know how far along that thing is in
development I think they're still
working scripting stage on that so I
think very little is being confirmed
let's see I like lose fur after Netflix
took over cool oh let's see the
unaltered Star Wars a new hope could be
headed back to theaters huh it's a link
to an article it's not a website I've
ever heard of so I don't know whether or
not to trust them I mean that would be
cool but you know not holding my breath
what our troops are cliches be it in
literature TV movies that you love even
though they're used a lot I you know
what I love I love a heist and there's
nothing particularly original to be done
with heists anymore but I love it I love
assembling the crew
I love the planning I love seeing how
executing it has to vary slightly from
the plan because something goes wrong or
there was a part of the plan that we as
the audience didn't already know about
oh they they there is nothing new Under
the Sun when it comes to to heist but I
really do enjoy them those are a good
time for me how worried are you about
the racnoss I mean I don't know I hope
they do something interesting okay pop
it on back what if ten men met 13 I
believe this could happen because we
would occur antenna our friends in real
life I'm sure he'd be up for his
question of whether or not anyone would
right sit and ask them to do it and he
can fit it into schedule in hindsight is
the war doctor necessary you could have
just said McGann destroy Gallifrey then
regenerated into Eccleston the war
doctor I'm not sure the war doctor was
ever necessary I do still think it was a
cool eye
though and I kind of liked the idea of
not and given like I guess some of the
stuff that's gone on with Big Finish
maybe wasn't necessary but I kind of
like I kind of like that Moffat made the
decision to not dirty up an existing
doctor and have them be the one who did
all these horrible things during the war
because you know would any of the other
doctors be truly capable of what the war
doctor had to do I don't know so I'm not
sure if he was necessary but I simply
was a cool concept and I respect the
choice to do it did you ever watch the
TV series hustle I did not contact
someone was bemoaning there were no xmas
specials anymore the quote of yours I
used was fans are never happy but they
like to remember a time they thought
they were that wasn't a bad that wasn't
a bad quote oh cool
who's better River Song Rose Tyler river
on the revisit I'm not a huge rose fan
she's not bad I don't have issues with
rose the way the way I have issues with
someone like Clara but as far as the
main companions go the ones you know
where the actor has their name in the
opening titles Rose she's in contention
for the bottom spot having declared the
love of heist movies what is what is
your current memory of time heist I
remember wanting to like it more than I
did but it's been a while since I've
seen it so oh my god imagine if River
met 30
oh she be all over River wooden Oh
like I do kind of want to see that like
not make a huge thing out of it but I do
just want to see how Alan Alex Kingston
would you know act River taking in that
that visual information
last year forced my family to listen to
the chime
midnight this year I'm dressing as the
8th doctor and quoting it and on
Christmas Eve because I am I am nothing
I am no one
chimes at midnight was really good
seriously if anybody if you have the
money to drop on it if you're gonna
listen to a Big Finish
especially in this month listen to the
chimes of midnight it's really good
Lovecraft's views aren't even subtle in
his work i wonder how people find it
easier I wonder if people find it easier
to deal with because it's horror born of
people's fears and paranoia I think that
might be part of why I don't want to say
he necessarily gets a pass I think
there's a lot of deconstruction around
Lovecraft's racism but I think that
might be part of why even though it is
evident in the work itself
it still kind of works because it is
playing on fears and his fears were
heavily racially motivated but because
he kind of transformed that into also
this this fear of these other you know
the the old ones and the Elder Gods and
all this cosmic horror stuff it it
transitions from a more traditional
straight-up racism to this fear of
something bigger and even more
unknowable and because those things kind
of feed into each other narrative ly and
thematically they do work in tandem it
does function that might be part of it
let's see oh I am gonna be wrapping it
up soon backing it up I've seen River
meets Missy bodies fell oh the visual
representation when thirteen isn't
expecting it River be giving 13 a
squeeze from behind
ha ha ha that just comes in from behind
hello sweetie chimes of midnight is free
on Spotify oh well there you go
if you have a Spotify go get chimes at
midnight mmm so good
I really more sirens and Doctor Who in
fact there's character named Anubis
whose suit ex son of course who's also
campaign the recent Tenth Doctor comics
huh interesting the comics are like I
have not gotten into it all I don't
really plan to you can make any version
of the master face any version of the
doctor who would you choose I would like
to see Capaldi go off again go up
against Roger Delgado's version of the
master
that would have been awesome you're
gonna listen to a lot of early Big
Finish on Spotify oh cool best thing to
come from the war doctor other than John
freaking hurt well yeah if John freaking
heard was that who viens now have McGann
hurt Eggleston
like seven eight nine love the concept
of the war doctor there was something I
saw and now I lost it
if they postponed the husbands of river
song to Jodi Zahra um I mean like that's
that's the one thing about the idea of
bringing river back her story really is
done I'm actually not sure it's a good
idea to bring her back but I did enjoy a
river
I had fun with her and I am gonna wrap
it up soon I think that I did I miss
something
okay sorry have you kept up with the
mandalorian I am one episode behind it's
pretty good I don't love it but it's
pretty good it's very good at being what
it intends to it's this question of how
much of a mood I am for what it is
intending to be time heist aimed high
but ended like a pole-vaulter who got
close but it magically at the bar there
should be a list of every terrible thing
the doctor has been forced to do by a
writer
Iggy's Stefan tells days to get over
being sexually assaulted in a book oh
wow I'm not sure I ever want to see that
list speaking personally I have this
Doctor Who book which has a bit from
River talking about the thirteenth
doctor and this part of its ripped out
that nearly reveals the doctor knows
thirteenth is female who knows have you
heard that a critic complained that Ford
versus Ferrari was to white man white
male dominated what do people expect
from a biopic oh I would ask for a link
to that cuz and like not to doubt you
but that sounds like the sort of thing
that it just reminds me of the baby's
cold outside thing were like certain
people like to go oh they ban it from
the radio and like that hasn't ever
really had like a couple of stations on
their own decided to take it off
rotation a couple places did like
listener polls and pretty much any time
that happened to stayed on so I I that's
the kind of thing that I hear that and
I'm like show me a link to the review
that says that cuz that that doesn't
sound right that that doesn't pass a
sniff test for me apparently some random
celebrity that no one knew about before
said he doesn't like em see you very
much five dead four bodies missing it
does feel that way sometimes doesn't it
all right Marvel fandom needs to chill
they do like here's the main thing I'm
an admitted Marvel fan I like most of
what they do but man when I criticize
Marvel they come out of the woodwork and
they nail me to the wall it's unpleasant
do you think tenet story is told to me
him saving Gallifrey is the perfect last
time to see him um
I mean maybe I'm really like tenon so
like I wouldn't mind seeing him back
I've always assumed that eventually the
mmm the meta-crisis doctor that want off
with Rose will be brought back
eventually when David Tennant is at an
age where he can't pass for the age he
was when he was playing the doctor
anymore because it was established that
the meta doctor the meta-crisis doctor
will age so I fully expect him to come
back in ten years the ward doctor is
definitely a Slytherin going from the
audios he was born to make the difficult
choice he's not evil he doesn't enjoy
making them but he still has to make
them yeah
yeah that that sounds pretty pretty
Slytherin so Pam
okay had to finish that off who so uh
yeah I am gonna wrap it up there and I
hope everybody has a good rest of the
week quick okay may I recommend the
League of Gentlemen dark British comedy
I've seen like trailers and stuff it
didn't look like my cup of tea if I'm
being honest anyways I am going to wrap
it up there so thank you all for tuning
in
I hope everybody had a good Thanksgiving
weekend if you celebrate it
I know I did I had a really good weekend
overall seeing friends seeing family
including some friends who I hadn't seen
in a while so yeah it's been pretty nice
which is good because you know days are
crazy short and it's cold and whatever
comfort I can get I will take happily so
just remember folks you are beautiful
you are valid you are loved you are the
council I'm just running the meetings
have a good night folks